um you talk about how to physically
escalate and make a girl dtf how do you
do such a thing
well uh the demonstration shows it
pretty well but the quick synopsis is
that
it's a combination of uh very great
thumbnail bro yeah yeah that's probably
the lucky girl uh carla this only fans
chick i used to hook up with okay uh
but yeah so what you do is you do a
combination of things so it's proximity
getting a little closer to the girl that
builds sexual tension light touches
strong eye contact it's just about
building as much sexual tension as
humanly possible before you make a move
and then once you do the girl is like
really horny and she wants to [ __ ] you
that's basically what i show in the
video and then and then the video is a
really good video because we're like
doing that demonstration end of the
video like while she was like on me like
really turned on i gave her a wet willy
and that was like the ending of the
video
gotcha [ __ ]
i love the mansplaining position you
you've acquired in every single i know
it works it looks like a casting couch
that's like a joke on my channel
well it works bro that video crushed it
yeah
let me ask you you believe in the 90 10
rule what's what's that 90 10 rule is
like you don't ever just go kiss a girl
you go 90
and she has to come to last ten percent
somewhat i have a more nuanced version
of that so before i kiss a girl i will
do a whole bunch of things like i will
get a little bit closer and if the girl
pulls back you know she doesn't want to
be kissed so you can prevent yourself
from getting rejected so i'll move in a
little bit then i'll move in a little
closer now brush past her hair then i'll
stare closer and eyes then i'll get
closer then i'll get closer then i'll go
for the kiss so the 90 10 rule something
like that uh nikki 90 10 rule do you
want to be the person like do you want a
guy just coming to kiss you or do you
want him just come get like straight up
almost there
kind of sexual
but then you have to kiss the guy i feel
like okay so this is a little different
i feel like when i meet a guy i'm
interested in
within 30 seconds to a minute i'm gonna
know if i want to like be with him or
[ __ ] him 30 seconds to a minute yeah
super common yeah is that very common
yeah yeah would you say that
yes yeah girl you know within the first
minute of meeting guy whether you're
going to do it or not it can get better
it can get better can it get worse
though it can also get worse but i know
for sure like you get an idea you get an
idea yeah that's how you get an idea in
the first minute
maybe like five minutes five it takes
five minutes from time to time
she's a lady guys gives her five minutes
can i have two pieces of advice right
now
this is me personally please do not wait
till the end of the date to go in for
the kiss it is so awkward you know it's
gonna happen and then you feel obligated
it's just do it in the middle sometimes
and you absolutely know if she wants to
it's so obvious whatever they do in
there the girl's like hell no and then
you have to well then there you go the
date's over
if they're a bad kisser it's a wrap and
if you're not running like yeah this is
a bad kiss you gotta get the body
language up until that point said don't
kiss then you don't kiss her at all and
i also hate when guys go can i kiss you
you're like okay
yeah absolutely not okay so we have wait
listen we're looking for some concern
women do not like when a guy says can i
kiss you no ew stop it the social
justice warriors are gonna come after
you for that statement wow i think you
can establish consent without verbal you
know check all the boxes where you see i
agree with that i've been criticized for
that though a lot on tick tock yeah i
think it depends how you ask and like
you know no i agree don't don't know
cute
it's super cringy you know you could be
like i really want to kiss you right
yeah that could make it sexual and
she'll be like okay so this is why we're
like
this is why you're gonna say
can't i kiss you
no you don't ask you you're assertive
don't ask just tell yeah i want to kiss
you right now that's that's better
actually i like that nicki that's way
better it's like a consent but like
friends out there in nigeria and
oklahoma and texas in florida that are
watching this right now everyone all
around the world you go you find a lady
right now you just tell her right now
bro
i want to kiss you girl yes and just do
it and just do it go ahead i mean no not
just
no no no no no not just do it say i want
to kiss you right now and then see how
she actually like i want to kiss you too
and she's like
well i don't really want to kiss right
now let's go do whatever we're doing
yeah if she says no then don't do it
great so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire sauz cast click
right here
[Music]